vous voyez les balles de ping pong entre
les regroupe le conseil de l'europe la
commission européenne et cetera quand
vous voyez que les ministres des
finances des 27 euros au terme d'une
réunion de l'eurogroupe se sont levés et
ont applaudi parce qu'on avait réussi à
avoir un plan de 540 millions de
milliards d'euros qui est pratiquement
composée de dette
quand vous voyez que la commission
européenne a parlé d'un montant ne sait
pas encore si c'est 1 5 milliard mais
qui va être constituée essentiellement
d'edf vous vous dites qu'il n'ya pas de
solidarité l'europe l'europe fonctionne
comme le père fouettard qui vient vous
dire que vous avez dépassé le déficit et
que vous avez dépassé la dette
le critère du déficit il a été mené mais
il n'y a pas du tout de solidarité et
moi ce que je pense c'est que les pays
du sud si ça continue comme ça les pays
du sud vont être abandonnés à leur sort
et on a déjà remarqué par exemple
agences de notation fitch a déjà changé
la perspective du portugal perspective
de la dette souveraine portugaise de
positive à stable
est ce qu'on a remarqué dans les
derniers jours c'est que tous les taux
d'intérêt des dettes souveraines sur le
marché sur les marchés financiers
l'italie de l'espagne du portugal et
même de la france ont commencé à
augmenter
donc ça ça annonce ça c'est le prix but
peut-être d'une nouvelle crise de la
zone euro d'une répétition ce qui est
passée ce qui se passe en 2012 mais ils
révisent leurs éditions un plus large
échelle et notamment parce qu'il ya des
normes donc cette banque centrale
européenne qui ne financent pas
directement les états contrairement à la
serre contrairement à la bombe chypre
contrairement maintenant même à la
banque d'angleterre la banque centrale
européenne ne finance pas les états dont
il va y avoir des besoins de financement
tellement important après cette pandémie
que les états vont être obligés de ce2
de se tourner vers comme si lancé auprès
des marchés financiers puisque la banque
centrale européenne ne finance pas elle
finance les bons mais elle ne finance
pas les états et que dans ces marchés
financiers vont pouvoir spéculer sur les
dettes et des demandes et des taux
d'intérêt beaucoup plus important donc
je pense qu'elle a raison si les choses
continuent d'être ce qu'elles sont
maintenant c'est l'europe continue
d'être ce qu'elle est maintenant
on marchera pas sûr et rapide vers une
nouvelle crise de la zone
[Musique]